today we're talking about maritime law
which is why i'm standing next to my
yacht the legal seagull wait where did
it go
damn you pirates
[Music]
ahoy legal eagles today we're talking
about pirates specifically sea pirates
and the law of the sea because believe
it or not pirates actually had a huge
effect on not only the founding of our
country but also the way that our laws
were shaped both domestically and
internationally so let's talk about what
it means to be a pirate and why that's
incredibly illegal so first we need to
talk about what laws govern the ocean
and there's actually three overlapping
types of law first there's maritime law
which is generally the law related to
private ships and commercial shipping
and then there's admiralty law which
generally relates to the law of shipping
whether it's navigable waters in rivers
or on the ocean itself and then there is
the law of the sea which is an actual
thing that is the international law
related to the use of oceans and seas so
uh maritime and admiralty law tends to
be domestic while the law of the sea
tends to be the international rules
amongst different nations now shipping
was incredibly important to the united
states when it was a new nation and
that's why it's mentioned several times
in the u.s constitution article 3
defines the boundaries of subject matter
jurisdiction for the courts specifically
it extends to the judicial power of the
united states to quote all cases of
admiralty in maritime jurisdiction and
if you're a u.s lawyer dealing with
maritime law you're probably dealing
with laws like the merchant marine act
of 1928 also known as the jones act this
act gives sailors the right to sue
negligent sea captains and companies if
they're injured on the seas and it also
highly restricts the type of ships that
are allowed to transport goods in the
united states specifically the jones act
says that any ship that transports goods
between two different u.s states has to
be built in the united states be owned
75 percent by u.s citizens be crude at
least 75 percent by u.s citizens and fly
a u.s flag now you're probably thinking
who cares this is just an esoteric law
about ships but it actually has a huge
impact on the u.s economy and for you my
fellow u.s consumer can make things
incredibly expensive for example the
cost of shipping one container from los
angeles to shanghai is about nine
hundred dollars whereas the cost of
shipping that same container from los
angeles to hawaii is about ten thousand
dollars and as a result states like
alaska and hawaii and territories like
puerto rico have incredibly high
shipping rates just to get things from
one state to another whereas those rates
often don't apply to foreign countries
and while you might be thinking hey it's
good for american shipbuilders and
american sailors well there aren't
actually that many u.s shipbuilding
basically doesn't exist anymore outside
of the defense industry there are less
than 100 ships that meet the
requirements of the jones act so in
times of emergency
sometimes these states are just
completely screwed this might be the
dumbest law on the books it's enough to
drive you to piracy which is what we're
going to talk about next so it might not
surprise you to learn that if you commit
the act of piracy on the high seas you
can be prosecuted as such and during the
golden age of piracy there were
thousands and thousands of pirates
operating in the caribbean and off the
barbary coast which had a huge effect on
the formation of this nation in the
caribbean they boarded merchant ships
from britain the netherlands france and
portugal and played big powers against
each other some of their exploits are
legendary blackbeard captured a former
slave ship named the concorde renamed it
queen anne's revenge and blockaded
charleston harbor in 1718. piracy was
such a menace that it made its way into
the constitution article 1 section 8
clause 10 gives congress the power to
quote define and punish piracy in
felonies on the high seas and offenses
against the law of nations and in 1790
congress used that authorization to
create the first anti-piracy act and
this had nothing to do with software was
about actual sea pirates the statute to
find piracy as murder or robbery on the
high seas or any other crime committed
on the high seas that would be
punishable by death under u.s law if
committed on land the supreme court held
that the 1790 statute was limited in its
scope and american courts couldn't
penalize people who committed piracy if
they weren't american citizens sailing
on a u.s flag vessel or if they didn't
inflict actual harm on u.s citizens
congress eventually amended the law in
1819 specifying the piracy didn't need a
specific nexus to the united states
that's actually very rare in law because
if you have watched this channel before
you know that standing is an incredibly
important requirement for almost any u.s
lawsuit or prosecution however rather
than defining what piracy meant as it
did in the original statute it referred
to the crime of piracy as defined by the
law of nations the punishment for piracy
under the 1890 law was death in 1909 the
penalty was changed to life imprisonment
and the 1909 law hasn't been amended
since its passage and it's found at 18
usc 1651 but the first challenge of the
1819 law came swiftly in 1820 when a man
named smith participated in mutiny on a
private vessel commissioned by the
colony of buenos aires smith and his
mates imprisoned the captain seized
another pirate ship called the
irresistible and robbed a spanish vessel
smith was convicted of piracy but he
took his conviction to the supreme court
smith argued that the definition of
piracy was too vague but the court
disagreed the supreme court held that
piracy was defined with reasonable
certainty by the law of nations and that
robbery on the high seas was a component
of piracy the nations hate piracy and
they hate pirates which is why they want
to prosecute pirates whenever they can
so the u.s and many other developed
countries have taken a universal
approach to this kind of law this kind
of international law is actually very
rare but it did serve as a template for
the prosecutions in nuremberg and tokyo
following world war ii now it took 200
years for the u.s to prosecute another
case of piracy but in 2010 the us
actually prosecuted two different cases
of piracy the first u.s versus state
involved pirates who shot at the uss
ashland the pirates boarded a small
skiff and fired weapons at the ashland
but didn't attempt to board the pirates
move to dismiss the case since they
didn't board or take control of the uss
ashland and the us district court
granted the motion the court said that
the piracy statute only allowed
prosecutions for quote robbery or
forcible depredations upon the sea the
definition given to piracy by the united
states supreme court in smith 190 years
earlier but in the sister case in u.s
versus hassan the fourth circuit
expanded the definition of piracy beyond
just robbery in that case somali pirates
mistakenly thought a u.s military vessel
the uss nicholas was actually a merchant
ship the pirates opened fired on the
ship and the uss nicholas crew fired
back the pirates agreed to flee but they
were captured and brought to the u.s
where they became the first men
convicted of piracy in 200 years they
were given life sentences however the
men thought that they could appeal based
on the sage case they had not boarded
the uss nicholas nor did they rob the
vessel unfortunately for them the fourth
circuit expanded the definition of
robbery and upheld the convictions the
court held that when congress enacted 18
usc 1651 and provided for piracy to be
defined by the law of nations congress
knew that the definition of piracy would
expand and evolve as the law of nations
evolved the court noted that the
international definition of piracy has
included many actions beyond robbery and
murder the forced circuit held that
limiting the definition of piracy to
robbery on the high seats would quote
render it in congress with the modern
law of nations and prevent the federal
courts from exercising universal
jurisdiction in piracy cases the fourth
circuit reversed the dismissal of the
piracy count in seid the bottom line is
that under modern u.s law piracy on the
high seas involves things other than
just robbery so pirates be prepared to
walk the plank and at this point we're
pretty good at prosecuting pirates
america kicking pirates ass since 1801
with i guess a few exceptions to that
rule unfortunately we've replaced
pirates with trash the oceans are
absolutely clogged with trash which is
why it's time that we all did something
about it which is why i joined team cs a
group of youtube creators who are trying
to raise 30 million dollars to remove 30
million pounds of trash from the ocean
now this is normally the part of the
video where i would talk about
curiosity's dream in nebula but this is
more important and that's why curiosity
stream decided to donate their sponsor
time to allow me to tell you about team
c's it couldn't be more simple there's a
link on screen and below this video
right now that will take you to the
donation button for team c's and if you
could donate i'd really appreciate it
100 of the proceeds go to our partners
the ocean conservancy and the ocean
cleanup and it couldn't be easier the
link below will take you to the donation
page for team seas and no amount is too
small one dollar means one less pound of
trash that makes it into the ocean five
dollars means five pounds of trash and
plastic that won't be in the ocean
together we can rid the ocean of plastic
and trash the same way that we rid the
ocean of those dirty pirates
now if you'll excuse me i'm gonna go
find my boat
you